this video was brought to you by g2
a.com for helping us support with
$50,000 for the charity campaign they're
a digital games marketplace for pretty
much everyone and everything check them
out I'll leave a link in the description
how's it going bros my name is pure Pat
I got some fantastic news
in March we started our Save the
Children charity campaign our original
goal was $250,000 but we completely
crushed it and lined it on three hundred
and forty thousand dollars but wait
together with what you bros donated and
with humble bundle and the private donor
in total we reach six hundred and thirty
thousand dollars that is so mind-blowing
ly awesome I can't thank you both enough
two years ago we started our first
charity campaign for WWF after that we
did st. Judas Hospital and not long ago
charity water and now Save the Children
putting all those together we have
reached over 1 million dollars towards
charities how fricking that is I can't
what I can't what this realizing that is
literally the best thing ever I I just
love how we can turn this stupid channel
let's be honest air bros it's pretty
dumb making these silly videos every day
and turn that into something that helps
change the world into a better place
that is just so cool and I could never
do that without you brush so thank you
so much you are you're the best
seriously 1 million dollar sports
charities is just insane
I I feel so proud of you as always bros
there's a breakfast for you stay awesome
but I know you will
[Music]